In addition to different miss rates
depending on whether we're looking
globally or locally at the cache
in a multi-level cache,
we have what is called
an inclusion property.
The inclusion property
has to do with assuming
that the block is in level one cache.
Is it that it may or
may not be in the level two cache, or,
it has to be in the L2 cache?
And it is also possible to make
a system in which if a block is in L1,
it cannot also be in L2.
This is often called exclusion.
This is what we usually call inclusion
and this doesn't have a name.
It's neither exclusion nor inclusion.
So if we just have a normal
cache hierarchy where
processor accesses go to level one
cache and then the misses from that go
to a larger level two cache cash,
the question is what will we get?
And the answer is, unless we
explicitly try to force inclusion or
exclusion, we will get this.
Most of the stuff that is in L1
will also be found in L2, but
there is no guarantee for that.
So there could be blocks in L1
that have been replaced from L2.
Let's look at the simple example,
when the L1 cache has two blocks and
is fully associative, and the larger
level two cache has four blocks and
is fully associative.
And both of them use LRU policy.
Now let's suppose that
the processor accesses block A.
It's going to be a miss here,
and a miss here.
It's brought from memory.
Placed here and
then that is fed to the L1 cache so
it places it here, so so
far we have inclusion.
Let's now access block B,
it gets brought from memory here and
here.
We still have inclusion.
If we now access block C,
it will be here and here and
we still have inclusion, but let's
suppose that when we have the blocks
A and B brought in, we reaccess A.
That is going to be a level one hit.
So know the areal count
is in level one of this,
but because there has been no access
when A was reaccessed to level two,
because it was a level one hit,
so we don't go to L2.
Here we still have that B is
the most recently accessed,
A is the next most recently accessed,
and let's say these two are like this.
Now let's say we access C.
What's going to happen is we
have a miss in the L1 cache,
we have a miss in the L2 cache.
We bring in C and replace the least
recently used block which is this.
The counters now get updated to
be three, two, one, and zero.
And then C is brought into
this level one cache and
replaces B, because that's
the least recently used block.
And the counters become one and
zero here.
So now let's say A's accessed again.
That changes the counters
back to this and
there is no axis to the level two cache.
Let's say now we access block D,
it's going to be fetched here.
The counters are updated to three two,
and zero.
And D is also brought into the level
one cache and placed here.
Of course that updates
the counters this way.
Now, let's say A's accessed again.
Now, we have the counters again,
one, zero.
Let's say, now, E is now accessed.
It's a miss in both caches.
We bring E in and now in the L2 cache,
it replaces the least recently
used block, which is A.
However, in the L1 cache, it will
replace the least recently used block,
which is D.
So at this point,
we no longer have inclusion.
Because A is in the L1 cache but
is no longer found in the L2 cache.
So inclusion does not necessarily
hold when you have a cache hierarchy,
because things that are frequently
accessed in the L1 cache,
will not be frequently may be accessed
in L2, because all of the accesses to
that block are going to L1,
and the L2 never sees them.
So eventually that block
gets replaced from L2.
To maintain inclusion properly,
we have to have a so
called inclusion bit added to L2,
which is one.
If that block is also in L1 and
when we replace things from
L2 we prevent blocks whose inclusion
bit is one from being replaced.
That ensures that we never replace
something that is is still in L1.
So we can maintain inclusion, but
again, that requires an additional bit.